is it possible that NASA has not told
the general public everything they know
about the planet Mars take for example
the popular discussion whether life ever
existed on Mars which NASA has stated
was possible but it had to have been at
least three closer to four billion years
ago based on evidence of oceans lakes
and rivers once existing on Mars however
how could these terrain features which
are found throughout virtually the
entire surface of Mars have survived
billions of years of erosion and routine
sandstorms of tropical storm strength as
I'll be discussing here shortly
let me start off by showing you a very
short clip that I edited down of a
conversation between congressman
Rohrabacher and a NASA executive in July
of this year which you may have seen I
made a video on this topic and I'll
include a link for it at the end of this
video but for this video I'm making a
completely different point so take a
look at this ignore the part about
ancient civilization and that's discuss
you have indicated that Mars had a was
totally different thousands of years ago
is it possible that there was a
civilization on Mars thousands of years
ago so the evidence is that Mars was
different billions of years ago and well
yes and and there would be there is no
evidence that I'm aware of would you
rule would you rule that out that see
there's some people well anyways I would
I would say that is extremely unlikely
okay now again ignore the part about
ancient civilization for the point of
this video and just focus on the
thousands of years ago versus the
billions of years ago discussion how on
earth do these terrain features survive
that long period of time and of course
I'm gonna play devil's advocate here now
so themselves have shown evidence of
running water on Mars existing today
take for example the abundance of ice at
the North and South Pole of Mars and you
can see that these ice caps change
yearly based on season as well as the
fact that some of these ice portions do
exist in various mountain ranges and
craters on Mars so although there is
evidence of running water on Mars today
it's in certain areas and it doesn't
explain the fact that there are
water channels located thousands of
miles from any type of ice and they've
survived billions of years of routine
sandstorms these storms are absolutely
massive and just to clarify they're not
of hurricane strength like many people
have often thought and seen in movies
yet their tropical storm strength 70
miles an hour and they are so massive
that many of them can only truly be
appreciated from orbit and satellite
imagery and you can see here that many
of these storms will cover the entire
planet and go on for hours on end and
days on end in some cases and the
effects of these storms on the surface
are massive and you can see here the
differences on how the terrain changes
based off just one storm so if NASA is
so adamant that the surface of Mars was
different three closer to four billion
years ago which by the way dig into that
I'll have to make this is just me part
one there's other points to be made so
look forward to other videos but if you
look at the fine print and how they
explain these these billions of years I
mean it doesn't really make sense and
they don't have a way to prove it I mean
have we sent people to Mars to do the
testing these Rovers can only do so much
so how can they honestly state three
billion years four billion years why not
1 billion why not 500 million so getting
away from those timeframes we've seen
the evidence that just one massive storm
completely changes the terrain of Mars
altogether so how many sandstorms would
have happened over you know three four
billion years there's certainly more
than one a year I don't have a specific
number other than that may our routine
and they happen frequently
so what tens of billions of sandstorms
and yet there are existing evidence of
these lake beds water channels and
rivers I can understand some of the
larger terrain features lasting a very
long period of time maybe billions of
years take a look at these two photos
here of the same river that NASA claims
is evidence of ancient flooding from
billions of years ago this river is
nearly a thousand miles long a thousand
feet deep in almost four and a half
miles across absolutely massive and yet
they think that this would survive
billions of years of erosion how many
tens of billions of sandstorms is that
that would cover it up and reexpose it
the winds and sand of time would wear
away at the edges and we're supposed to
believe that this much evidence would
survive
three billion years but getting back to
these other photos of rivers that are
much much smaller evidence of creeks
evidence of streams and we're supposed
to believe that these would survive
billions of sandstorms so when it comes
down to it it's not appropriate to say
that these terrain features that are
thousands of miles of any ice source
whatsoever on Mars would survive
billions of years or even millions of
years or even hundreds of thousands of
years in fact thousands of years is the
appropriate estimate and many other
people are talking about this which is
why congressman Rohrabacher brought it
up to this NASA executive and he didn't
follow through right he didn't provide
the evidence he just let it go
he got weak in the moment but clearly
you can see and just think for yourself
that there's more to this story here
these terrain features do not survive
billions of years they don't survive
millions of years and I'm not saying
none of them would perhaps they're you
know when you have a thousand foot deep
river maybe that would survive a certain
period of time a very long period of
time but billions guys clearly there is
far more to the story of Mars than what
we've been told and there's other key
points that are worthy of mention so
consider this video just part one and
there will be others to come where I
outline evidence of massive
contradiction from what NASA has told us
based on evidence that we can see for
ourselves so I'll leave it at that like
and subscribe and leave me a comment
share your thoughts on all of this and I
have many other videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics take care
everybody